[Music]
a father who is no stranger to gun
violence is providing comfort to the
people of El Paso following the mass
shooting their manual Oliver travels the
world painting murals in honor of his
son Joaquin who died in last year's
school shooting in parkland Florida
Oliver happened to be in El Paso over
the weekend and Jonathan Vigliotti spoke
with him Jonathan what an incredible
journey for this man
it has been and what a tragic one - Dana
good morning to you Manuel tells me his
goal in all of this now is to give his
son a voice this is Joaquin's face over
the past 18 months Manuel has been going
town to town introducing Americans to
him one street corner at a time
my role number one here as a father is
to let everybody know what you to let
you know who [ __ ] Oliver is not what
yes Manuel Oliver's son Joaquin would
have turned 19 yesterday he was one of
17 students gunned down in the Parkland
school shooting last year his father's
mission since then to give his son a
voice demanding change on gun violence
one mural at a time
El Paso just happened to be his next
stop and I got the news on my phone
everybody's tweeting because they knew
that I was in the bathroom and I said oh
okay
I happen again the shooter allegedly was
targeting Mexicans and immigrant Pinos
you're an immigrant as well do you feel
safe walking around the streets here
putting up a mural I don't think any of
us should feel safe we're all targets
and and as long as we don't do anything
about it
that's what we're fighting for in
February
Oliver interrupted a Capitol Hill
hearing on universal background checks
when one congressman instead advocated
for building a border wall this is not a
blue or red thing it's a social issue
so it's both efforts I need to get out
there and send the right message part of
that message to stop spreading hate when
you hear some politicians tell American
citizens to go back home if you tell me
go home this is home for me
I wasn't lucky enough to be born here
like many of you I decided to move with
my family and make it to another nation
looking for for a first world country
life and the price that I paid for that
is losing my son a father fighting for
change by keeping the faces of the lives
lost in our minds what do you see when
you look at this what do I see in him
yeah I see an activist not a victim and
this mural was meant to be a birthday
celebration but in light of this
weekend's attacks that message has
slightly changed manual writing El Paso
no es sólo el paso you are not alone
Dana I asked him if he thought these
murals would raise awareness and open
the eyes of Americans to gun violence he
said he hopes so all right Jonathan a
good message I think everybody hopes so
and he's not alone you know I have a 19
year old son I so admire what he's doing
in his son's name here it's really
powerful to me yeah I wait for him to
find some peace and that's got to be
tough yeah